passé le micro mais s'il vous plaît et
interviews mais ça tant qu'ancien auprès
de lui pour parler dans le micro faut
parler dans le micro en vous ça fait un
an que les lycéens se mobilisent
on parle d'un visibilisation il ya un
truc dont vous parlez pas demain il ya
aussi une marche contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes on n'en parle pas
versus violence dans les zones à la
violence dans les hôpitaux on a parle
pas les violences qu'a que l'on
rencontre des jeunes on n'en parle pas
les ehpad on en parle bien sûr on fait
un public ici on n'en parle pas ici des
seuls porte parole c'est des gens qui
touchent à 1,7 million fin et de parents
il faut arrêter de déconner et
aujourd'hui on dit gilet jaune payet et
payet gilet jaune arrêter les étiquettes
aujourd'hui on a ça en commun qui a une
colère mais je suis un gars là pour dix
ans pas sex du mékong ou d'idées et là
ça fait ça fait ça fait sans déconner ça
fait deux heures qu'on est ici à faire
les pots de fleurs moi j'aime bien faire
de mon vendredi et volets fois on
m'avait dit qu on m'avait dit que je
pouvais venir pour parler des jeunes je
peux pas parler d'elle jeune on est ici
à temps pour faire les pots de fleurs
pendant deux heures mais calmez vous
j'ai mieux à faire de dix prévenus pour
faire des ddd des eaux à la balle et ma
portée ça fait deux heures que vous êtes
là pour vous on vous écoute n'avait un
long mail a donné la parole
c'est une habitude ont dû aviser qu'il y
avait des bonbons haribo la mi-temps
beaucoup
il nous a fait une sortie il nous a fait
mal je sais pas ils veulent en bois tu
voles en bois
mais à mon avis il a eu un sms tu viens
pas la soirée bon temps changent et à
bon escient par la food & noble aux six
mois
[Applaudissements]